hey guys it's November 14th and we just
finished up our 72 hour livestream for
extra life where we raise money for kids
and we met our goal good job guys yay
I'm chastity I've got your news for
today first up the new xbox Scorpio
console will deliver really true 4k
according to an Xbox exec Microsoft's
project Scorpio console is slated to
arrive in holiday 2017 Xbox executive
aaron greenberg has discussed the
upcoming xbox console saying it's
capable of delivering quote really true
4k this will really bring the most
powerful console you've ever seen
greenberg said at this weekend's xbox
fan fest it will bring these really true
4k really incredible visual games that
we've never seen before on the console
people have spent thousands of dollars
on a high-end PC are getting that
experience how do we bring that to a
scale in a console in your living room
that's a big part of what project
Scorpio is all about he added Microsoft
has said that all of its first party
games will run at a native 4k after the
e3 Scorpio announcement Microsoft has
not offered much in the way of specifics
about the console greenberg said
Microsoft is saving a good deal of
significant reveals about project
Scorpio for 2017 pricing for the project
Scorpio has not been announced but
Microsoft has repeatedly referred to it
as a premium device so it likely won't
be cheap next a watchdogs to easter egg
appears to tease a new Ubisoft space
game watch dogs too appears to contain
an easter egg that might be referencing
a new ubisoft game or it might be
nothing at all kotaku reports that there
is a mission in watch dogs to that
begins with the player intercepting a
call from a fictional Ubisoft marketing
person they talk about how Assassin's
Creed games in real life have a tendency
to leak before they are officially
announced I can assure you there's no
way the trailer is getting out a fake
Ubisoft employee says to another can you
can you assure me the boss replies after
what happened with unity syndicate or
Cyrus after this omission titled you be
stolen begins and your task is to visit
Ubisoft San Francisco office which is
actually in the game you climb onto the
roof and eventually steal a game trailer
by hacking into the network the title
appears to be some kind of RAD looking
space game that Ubisoft in the watchdogs
to fiction what announced at e3
watchdogs to comes out on November 15th
for PlayStation 4 and Xbox one before
arriving on pc on november 29th and
finally the skyrim special edition 1.2
patch is out on
PC and ps4 here's what it does following
its beta launch last week on PC the
newest update for Skyrim special edition
has arrived in full for computers and
ps4 update 1.2 is slated to arrive
sometime later this week on xbox one
Bethesda said on Twitter as detailed
previously 1.2 focuses on improving
performance and resolving various issues
and crashes including one that could
trigger when changing from werewolf back
to human form it also makes improvements
to the mod browsing experience the full
patch notes can be seen on gamespot com
it doesn't appear that this uptick deals
specifically with the reports of update
1.1 causing crashes across PC ps4 and
Xbox one for its part but does the said
it's investigating those crashes but
there's no word yet on when a fix will
arrive or if any workarounds currently
exist let me know what you think of
today's stories in the comments below
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time